Many many years ago, there lived an Emperor .
He loved new clothes very much.
He would spend all his money on them.
He did not care for his country.
Nothing could please him except new clothes.
Throw them away!
By the way, the city which he ruled was full of life.
Many strangers from all over the world visited this city every day.
One day two swindlers came to the city.
Do you know that the Emperor is looking for some new clothes?
Again? He hired a famous designer a few weeks ago!
Right. But the Emperor got sick of his clothes.
This time, he will reward lots of gold to whomever makes the best clothes.
Really? What a good opportunity!
Who will get the chance?
The swindlers heard what the people said.
Shall we try?
Sure! There is no reason to refuse a lot of gold.
The two swindlers visited the Emperor the next day.
They introduced themselves as great weavers.